um people being annoying and so I know
when I did the bachelor nation Little
Miss Maximus I know he said something
then that was kind of like all right
he's they're trying to be hip or
whatever okay so how and that was last
year right that's probably a year ago
yeah yeah yeah like last finale last but
not lighted with me like six months or
something like that
yeah whatever would yeah because it was
on during the bachelor oh this is the
Bachelorette yeah right right okay so he
goddamn it dude I like I fell the [ __ ]
out laughing cuz obviously I had to
watch the finale
mhm which by the way went by the way
just hilarious okay just the whole thing
first of all their whole strategy of
like introducing these WWF storylines
and has worked mm-hmm like they're they
put the last Bachelorette it was like
supposed to be his Redemption story how
she got clowned by whoever she got
clowned in the finals of The Bachelor
like the weird racecar driver dude
didn't pick her oh he went back on it
oh she was on the last okay right they
always do that right yeah so he was on
the race car driver season which was a
lot the one that we were talking about
six months more or less whatever I got
you and this is her redemption story no
there was those so then they had her
redemption story okay and then this
season is another Bachelorette and like
the ratings improved by like 20 percent
or something like relative to hers okay
so just like the current season with
like Luke P and [ __ ] you know coming
through and Hulk smash in the proposal
and all that it worked for him is what
I'm saying so hats off to them but
basically she she chooses she passes on
Superman like like probably the closest
you get to Superman like as Clark Kent
like dudes tall comb-over jacked wide
chest he just you can fly oh yeah he
could definitely feel like he could fly
right into your pants that's for sure
flying anyway she passes on him for like
a five nine guitar-playing [ __ ] who
sort of I said he said he moved to
Nashville to like become a singer and
all this [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
had a girlfriend going into the show and
he told her he was just going on the
show for music and the Bachelorette
found out through like People magazine
or something like she read an article or
someone's like yeah this fool has a as a
girlfriend
damn yeah yeah that guy sucks yeah so
his first of all when they meet on
camera to like hash it out that's the
least energy I've seen someone put into
being sorry it was like wait wait he met
with the ex-girlfriend to hash it out no
no he met with because they were
technically still engaged at that point
but they weren't living in the same city
oh so she wait who was engaged so the
Bachelorette chooses guitar-playing
[ __ ]
yeah and so they get engaged they gonna
get he and then she finds out that and
that he had a girlfriend when he started
the show yeah through People magazine
damn yeah and then she starts going back
she she thesis the whole situation is
hilarious but this dude it was funny
watching him try to cry and he just
couldn't cuz he didn't care he just
really ya know like looking down yes
dude hey look seven yeah sorry
rubbing a whole onion in his eye like
please please let the make me sad cuts
the root and just staring in it it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen I'm gonna
feel something here I prom he cheated
them into his eye he's supreme patty
itself just nothing yeah doesn't even
blink when the [ __ ] hits his eyeball
he's like yeah I'm good I'm good how is
this possible so he he is of great
highlights in his speech one of them was
he says I you're the girl I want to
spend the rest of my life with so tell
me what I need to do to make this right
or something to that effect she she goes
I don't know I don't know and I was just
waiting for him he did sorry I was
waiting for him to cut the silence and
be like I'll write an album about you
that's what I'll do alright
album about you will will we it's not a
marketing play at all I've just you know
it's gonna be a 100% genuine for me and
you an album from me about you but it's
a you know they say that no I was
waiting for him to do it and he didn't
how sick would that be though if he said
that and then he did that and he went
back to his ex-girlfriend like told me
for the music I told you now I'm a
famous country singer dude I couldn't he
sang her a song when he proposed to her
and I'm like if that wasn't just him
auditioning himself hmm
Sarah I'm opposed to her I'm cheating on
us didn't matter I walk right after I'm
play this song and I'm gonna blow up
Spotify I'm gonna rip this song like not
even a love song this completes about a
truck she's like trying to figure out
the metaphors and stuff like right on
the end of the Sun said I must be the
Raptor yeah he's like no you're not it's
a it's a truck it's a really nice drugs
my truck that's the one I'm gonna buy if
this [ __ ] goes planet was after that she
says you know and I was thinking back to
after we got engaged and when I asked
you if you told people you said to me
yeah I told my friends I won awesome
boys I did it yeah yeah I told him I won
I won the [ __ ] show oh cool so you're
engaged yeah yeah but it's like a
condition of winner yeah you know me
that one have [ __ ] won I got first
place first place
didn't he has no idea that it's like
everything's real okay he just thinks
it's a game show yeah I was like telling
her I loved her stuff cuz like you know
do do it that's like they told me that's
part of it yeah part of it that's like
this is all one big yes not it's not for
real is it now dude I mean I actually
fell in love with her but just for the
game
so I am in love with her but it honestly
felt like The Bachelor trying to
convince people that the show still real
cuz his whole angle was I didn't know I
could find love on a reality show but I
did and now I lost it oh well so she
broke up with him
she calls it off yeah she ended up
calling it off the Superman comes on the
show then she asks him on a date and
then so this is the Little Miss Maximus
part okay so Chris goes so just to be
clear we're gonna give this a shot which
is [ __ ] strange cuz like okay they're
giving it a shot yeah it's weird that no
Chris is there to know I know their
every step you have for the show's over
I know it just got me thinking that
that's how invested people are in the
Bachelorette like they think they're
gonna date this fool yeah so he's like
we're gonna give this a shot and then
she's like well yeah I mean yeah he's
like like whites the audience down to go
well I think I speak for everyone when I
say we can ship this no way yeah in the
balls yeah I started dying laughing it
was like are you [ __ ] serious yeah
and all of America just gagged at the
exact same time I think everyone
watching that show was like yes we can
yes we can yes we can did you know she
had sex in a windmill hmm
oh that's what I was gonna say before
what can I do to make this up to you
please let me know you can you can take
me over there and [ __ ] my brains out
riding that way you know right there
okay yeah you [ __ ] oh my god what
about a song though I want you to take
me in dust my cheeks over there and that
windmill okay then I can play you a song
yeah we'll do the song after or because
I do want to do the songs well before
ordering we can do during - dude you
know people are gonna still listen to
his album oh yeah first let's see what
it's all about yeah I'm thinking about
it dude doing a couple tick-tock screws
Oh is expecting like when they go to the
commercial break listen to the song that
Jed wrote about Hanna after they broke
up now on Apple music just like I'm so
sorry dude she to both my ex-girlfriend
she [ __ ] she takes off the ring at
some point and think it was like oh and
he like she puts it down to get like a
shot of it nice and that whole thing
just feels like they're really bad at
ads like they do it like really 1940
style like instead of like a semi
innocuous like shot of like drinking
coca-cola they always do like some
really shoehorn [ __ ] where a good dude
from halo top just interrupts a date
okay feels like a Tim and Eric every
dress dressed like a big ice cream yeah
and like he'll be pushing like a branded
like thing and yeah he'll just be on a
date he's like anybody wants some ice
cream yeah I'm like oh my god I love
halo top and I eat out of a halo top
thing for like the whole date it's just
it's hilariously bad it's awesome yeah
look that's so sick we need [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that why don't we get endorsements
like that yeah
crazy crazy heavy endorsements just mid
podcast yeah that'd be so sick yeah and
I was running in my Nike [ __ ] Free
Run 3.0 is connected to my Apple watch
no no it's it's we're sitting here like
doing this and then the in and out guy
open I through order yeah
just comes in here is like what can I
get you boys oh man
you just read my mind I was totally
thinking I could go for a nice
double-double right now yeah I'm
famished
do an animal style fries please I just I
so sick better than the [ __ ] t-mobile
guys I know that was terrible oh they
don't know about that I know that's a
bonus episode episode watch the last
bonus SS sorry dude
did for you I just think we got a parody
The Bachelor but everything is like an
ad like like in the finales they always
show something and then cut to the
studio so I just thought it'd be really
funny if we just parody Chris thinking
wow Hannah really removed her $25,000
Kay jeweler drink in the middle just
like everything is like some type of
[ __ ] product like where Chris yeah
like we're Chris yeah
and it's like some dual life [ __ ] wow
I can't believe she talked about that
ring that marine was $25,000 $25,000
yeah Wow
actually pretty good value ever every
kiss begins with Kay it does you know
that ring can be financed for 0% down
now back to the bachelor just [ __ ]
dude this is actually Sam I related but
get get this [ __ ] okay this is what my
buddy was tell me yesterday when I first
started watching loved Island it was
when I went to London right and to visit
my friend yeah he's now in LA and he's
telling he's telling me about how like
how the season went down over there in
London
first of all ovie is like the biggest
celebrity now I'm sure in the UK
everybody [ __ ] loves him he's like
bit darling he like won the show yeah
cuz everybody [ __ ] loves him second
he told me that okay so the channel is
ITV right the production company that
produces it is called sling some some
weird name but they basically have had
hit after hit after hit they invented
wife swap hmm now they produce the love
Island and like a bunch of other like
super successful reality show so the guy
started it's like [ __ ] a billionaire
right it's like Ryan Seacrest yeah
whatever so their new show this is crazy
they basically take they take like a
couple or like a family from like every
you know walk of life every you know um
you know it's like a gay couple and then
it'll be like a posh couple and it comes
from you know yeah whatever and they all
watch big TV events so it'll be like
finale like the finale of love island or
like oh and they are you know and then
it shows it's basically just a giant
reaction video so it's like you watch
them watching the season and they edit
it so that you can see each person's
reaction their conversations to what's
happening oh weird isn't that meta as
[ __ ] yeah it's like a super big hit in
London apparently that's some [ __ ]
black mirror [ __ ] it kind of is right
now it is a little bit it is a little
bit it's like it would be like a like a
part of black mirror where it's like
everyone just loves watching other
people watch things yeah yeah that's
crazy it is pretty crazy I mean it's
crazy that it's working and I also feel
like it could only work there
mmm-hmm like Americans are like they're
not self-deprecating enough they can't
like watch themselves you know yeah yeah
that would be like it's they're like too
proud a hundred percent yeah cuz in
order to enjoy that show you have to
watch and be able to like make fun of no
we're we're soup I mean maybe you know
in culture a little bit I don't know I
mean I've heard that even the UK is like
it can be a bit divisive like as far as
like politics and stuff but I feel like
America obviously we can speak from that
like right now
[ __ ] super like divided yeah so a show
like that would just be like oh but
maybe that's the point I that's true I
thought it would I thought that was
doesn't lie that's what I mean they
argue like I felt like that's the
initial point of the show is like get
people like they're all separated so
yeah you basically just watch them in
their own context but I guarantee that
just triggers so much like discussion
yeah it's like that's what could make
the show a hit is like everyone talking
about it yeah Michael you have to see
it's super strange but this and that
yeah so I actually watched by the way if
you know what that's called blow up the
comments because I want to like watch it
and I forget the name of it but it's
someone I know so yeah yeah and to that
point I watched in an episode of
euphoria last night oh yeah okay so
how's that first off they plug the [ __ ]
out of love Island in the episode I
watched and it's like zendaya is like
character is like binge watching the
[ __ ] out of love island which makes me
think that love island is like sort of
culturally relevant culturally relevant
yeah like with younger people hmm
because like she's like like it's it's
not described how she's watching it but
she's like an American kid so it makes
me think like I wonder if a lot of young
people have like in gate like are
watching love island like bootlegged
like you know not us cuz we're oldest
[ __ ] yeah do you know me yeah yeah show
me yeah my brother Joe me yeah bro Ovey
Ovey sue what are you doing what you
doing that's Anna yeah when she was like
oh yeah just asked me to be a girls one
and he just walks over
I love how when Toby walked over he just
like pick up India just like one finger
just moved up in the situation
doofy be good for us to talk about it Oh
ever look should we discuss the finale
we can in a sec but I want to say so a
lot of people didn't like euphoria and
what I do know is that it was written by
a former addict mm-hmm now some people
felt like it's too much a love island
addict
hello violent No Oh like a rose yeah
yeah and it's like to Hollywood or like
it's too many things like working
together or like strung together and
like paints like a really dark image of
high school but watching I always have
only seen one episode watching one
episode I actually felt like well it was
really cool about it one it's shot super
crazy mm-hmm really like interesting
camera moves a lot of continuous takes
which I feel like you don't see in like
big-ass shows okay
big-ass shows always feel like shot
reverse shot shot reverse shot and it's
just like a lot of cutting and and
that's I think what kind of makes the
show cool is you have a lot of moments
where it's like dialogue for maybe two
three minutes straight and it's like
intense dialogue and the cameras like
like it's like slow sweeps it's like
moving around a table and it's like
moving between all the characters no cut
points hmm so it's like that's kind of
cool in that regard I actually felt the
shows interesting cuz it makes it feel
like it's almost like fantasy like it's
like this weird oh [ __ ]
it's a tug boy no no one's gonna get
that boy I meant tug Shaq talking about
Shaq text don't worry about the Tuck
Shack or about it um but I actually I
think the show I makes me want to go
back and watch the whole thing I think
that actually be pretty interesting I
get that like it might be like
overwhelming with how many like themes
are tied together but I do know they're
doing fentanyl in the first episode oh
yeah first or second but like but the
way I look at it is I kind of view it as
like like the fortnight of [ __ ]
teenage dramas okay where it's like all
these different elements are like pulled
into like one map okay it's like it's
kind of interesting that you know what
I'm saying like like like people people
who sell drugs you know people with sort
of like that
like they have like a trans actor on the
show and she liked it she like she's
she's like kind of I think she is either
it like either covers her transition or
she's like I don't think she's trans
just transitioning through the show but
like that's a part of it obviously like
drug abuse and it's just like a lot of
different things and I think it's kind
of interesting to weave them together so
actually I I don't know I have to go
back and watch the show and I'll
probably have tons of stupid [ __ ] to say
about it but I mean I think it was
ultimately it was cool to see high
school in a way that wasn't
[ __ ] Riverdale yeah every high
school show is [ __ ] dance and I'm
like high school does have dark ash
darkest moments yeah people yeah so it
was like you know I mean I guess 13
reasons why but that was just a podcast
yeah I've never watched that one either
yeah that was that was that was just
somebody promoting a podcast yeah okay
crazy-ass podcast promo if you ask me
and and eforea is just love island yeah
yeah love island frontally that's the
only thing we took from exactly yeah man
lots of intense themes but the love
island was in that [ __ ] yeah so Amba and
Craig yeah they they won they won
spoiler alert oh my god yeah you can you
just just reverse back a little bit yeah
you know what we're gonna say it then
you can skip over yeah our bed actually
don't really care um no but it was it
was good I'm I'm kind of glad they won I
thought that Tommy and Molly may were a
shoo-in I thought they were definitely
gonna win yeah because they were that's
like season one love and the most yeah
like together the whole thing like they
were always like the number one couple
like anytime the UK voted on anything
they would be number one yeah but I
think because they're a shoo-in that's
why people didn't want him to win I
thought it would be so I just thought
it'd be so funny if because you know how
they do the the split or share thing
oh if Molly no if Greg just kept the
money
Oh like he was there for like a week
and they're like yeah I'm gonna keep it
yeah come in I've got what I've need and
yeah oh yeah want the money yeah but
actually I was thinking we were really
funny is if you took the money and then
Michael came out he drags like oh he's
actually me mate and then Michaels is
like you have come to chat to where I've
come to chat to her to let her know like
like I can't like fully do it I have
been a bit of a [ __ ] but la good
Greg is my Nate they're be so funny and
she's just like I love the Newcastle
thing of using us either so I [ __ ]
love it
I so mean to us yeah it sounds creepy I
love it yeah it sounds like Smeagol a
little yeah he's being mean to us
he's been mean to us I've come to chat
to her hmm
yeah it was a it was a michael is a
white boy yeah that falls why - eh he's
[ __ ] bill - yeah he's got he's got a
[ __ ] build I feel like when he falls
it sounds like metal hitting the
pavement
yeah like clunk yeah I just don't get
like how do you [ __ ] like maintain
that just work out all the time steroids
mortgage Dusen I don't think he's Juicin
not probably not I think just one of
those dudes it's just naturally like
just one of them Arnold [ __ ]
made for it yeah and so and they're
[ __ ] so the next season is in
December yeah it's like they're gonna do
it twice a year now like that's a spec
that's it's [ __ ] sick um Curtis
mm-hmm exposed I like that his mom came
in was like we were so proud of you yeah
so proud of you we like - you're honest
with Amy I was like how could you be
proud of him yeah yeah he [ __ ] over
like three people on this show yeah
mm-hmm he's a he's a people-pleaser
I like when ovie just pulled him aside
yeah it's like just basically like a son
quit being a [ __ ] like you you just
need to pick a side
you can't be out down the middle and
wishy-washy he's basically just calling
them wishy-washy ass I don't know I like
that though it was funny when Chris told
who was it so he told Anna or he told
Maura that Jordan was gonna go and talk
to India or whatever right yeah and then
so everything blew up because of that
and then Chris was like what'd you do
and he was like I told Maura mm-hmm that
chilled and wanted to talk to India he
was like what was your thought process
behind that yeah yeah you mean Greg no
Chris said oh cool it was great yeah he
was like what the [ __ ] were you thinking
yes your thought process behind that
yeah zero code man though those people
the the [ __ ] loose lips sink ships
[ __ ] is crazy I want a Nana off the
[ __ ] show so yeah her overly
judgmental miserable ass yeah couldn't
like get stay out of people's [ __ ] she
has the argue I like the argument style
or the discussion style where you just
repeat a three word sentence over and
over and over again and that's how you
argue yeah yeah you know Amy do you not
hear me I'm sorry do not hear me do not
hear me do not hear me do you not hear
me do you not hear me you just asked me
to be your girlfriend girlfriend
girlfriend do you not hear me say
something else yeah just one thing one
other word thing maybe oh that's when I
listen I really loved Michael yeah when
he just like she'd do that and he's like
okay you're not listening yeah you're
not listening why am I here you're not
listening
you're a child yeah you're a child I
can't I can't even speak I can't even
speak okay son then it's done it's done
it's done then she hate him yes walk
away
oh yeah just walk away oh you just walk
away okay just walk away walk away walk
away
Jordan Jordan played it super cool at
the end yeah I know is that he just
that's all you can really do yeah in
that situation yeah it's just like when
she was like who's that right okay okay
stunning yeah yeah cool yeah Oh because
his [ __ ] face when he's talking to
India and she's like yeah I thought you
were my mate and there's that moment
where he just realized like everything
he just did yeah and he just goes Mae
and he just said everything is about to
come crashing down on him and he [ __ ]
knows it this is such a good shot it's
so good yeah the mate that like in like
the way like he draws back and like his
left shoulder it's like oh like like she
hate him like oh and you can just feel
the tension building auras talking to
Anna and that's just about to go down
and it's like [ __ ] yourself so good rope
but you know what I also loved was um
how goddamn it
oh how just clueless Anton was I love
how clueless he was so I go to like I go
to the clerk
and he's like I write down my number and
he's just chuckling away and she's like
what everyone's kind of like where's the
joke where's the joke and then spoiler
on spoilers yes sorry
spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert spoiler alert
say we should say it again I don't think
we got the bit a spoiler alert
[Music]